All right. This this is something very different
that I'm going to do. And let me know if you think
that that this is interesting for the show and
whether this is instructive. As many of you know,
and many people are mad about this. I don't talk
about politics with viewers via email. I'm so busy
doing the show that I can't respond to political
questions via email or engage in that way.
At this point, we get about 6000 emails, comments,
tweets, Facebook posts and the like every single
day. We would need multiple full time people if
the idea was to sort of like engage meaningfully
with every every comment. But every once in
a while, if there's something that I think
will be instructive, I will sort of jump in and
get involved. And indeed, I received an email
yesterday morning from an anti vaccine individual
spouting conspiracy theories. And I decided to
engage. I decided to actually let's see where
they're getting their information, how did they
come to hold the beliefs that they have. And so
I'm protecting her email address and last name.
But I am going to go through a conversation
I had via email with an anti Voxer named Amy
Now. Amy wrote to me yesterday morning with
the subject, a concerned viewer, and Amy said
about vaccines, just curious how you could
deceive others when it comes to the covid
and the vaccines. I'm well aware
that, you know, it's all a scam
and the so-called vaccines are causing deaths.
Now, there's there's probably five things
there to look at. The idea that I know that
it's a scam. What the virus or vaccination,
the so-called vaccine refers to people who say
these aren't actually vaccines causing deaths
refers to people who believe it is the vaccine
causing people to die rather than covid itself.
So there's a lot here. But let's let's get
a big picture view of what she's saying.
Amy goes on, Is money that important to you that
you have to go along with this now? Know who
would even pay me to say the vaccines? You know,
I really got a vaccine. Nobody paid me to do that.
Nobody's paying me to say that it was great.
I don't even know who would be willing to give
me money to do that. Amy goes on, People
are starting to despise you now. People
have despised me for a long time. That's not
she's right about that. But that's not new.
And you don't have to believe me. But all traders
involved in this scam will see a prison cell.
It's already mentioned in a couple lawsuits I
know of. So keep on with your nonsense and you
will see. So I actually decided to write back to
Amy and I said, no one has died from the vaccine.
We will not spread dangerous propaganda on our
show, to which Amy wrote me back very quickly.
I have proof. I also have proof from CDC documents
we are being played. The fact that you don't even
ask about the proof I have proves you are
involved in this scam. So up until this point,
the allegation is because I've not asked her for
the proof I'm part of the scam now. I actually
want to see where she is getting these ideas.
I want to see what documents, what websites,
what is it that these anti VAX conspiracy folks
are basing their ideas on? So I wrote back, OK,
send it, send me the stuff. I want to see
the proof. And Amy wrote back first without
even addressing the fact that I've asked for the
information saying, you know exactly what's up.
There are CDC documents admitting we're being
played, lawsuits filed, saying we're being played.
Mike Pompeo was asked one time if covid was a
hoax and he wouldn't answer. Now, that was for
political reasons, that that's not you know,
Mike Pompeo is secretary of state. He doesn't
know anything about. Immunology or epidemiology,
and she goes on to say, as for the fake vacs,
why would she get caught faking getting it? I
have that proof, too. This is a conspiracy that
Dr. Fauci pretended to be vaccinated, but that
he wasn't really injected. And then she finishes
her email by saying there's all kinds of death
reports and the list of proof goes on and on.
You do know all this now? Of course, I want
the proof now. So I simply wrote back to Amy,
please send me the documents so I can review
them lawsuits and documents. And now Amy says,
slowing down her responses a little bit, taking
a little more time between responses. Amy says,
I'll get the info together. Now, however, I feel
like this is a trick because I know how you people
work. You all want to know what info we have so
you can scrub it from the Internet. So this is
interesting. First evidence of my malfeasance
was that I didn't ask for the proof. Now it's
suspicious that I am asking for the proof and
of course, the idea that I can just have things
scrubbed from the Internet. You know, we're now
going many levels deep. Amy says, I'm not stupid
and I don't trust anyone. There's no way you don't
know this, especially doing what you do while
I'm getting the info. Here is the name of one
attorney dealing with a lawsuit, Ryner Rolnick.
And a question still is, why wouldn't Mike Pompeo
answer? When asked if covid was a hoax, why would
Dr. Fauci fake getting the so-called vaccine?
There's no way you wouldn't know what's up.
So I wrote back again. I'm remaining very
calm and I just said, it's no trick. I
want to see the info. Amy writes back, I'm
getting the info together. And like I said,
Ryner Rolnik is one of the attorneys and he admits
it's fraud. Again, we don't know what is fraud.
Little more time goes by. Amy sends me another
email. I just ran across this about the inventor
of the tests they're using for covid. He
tells you it can't detect if you're sick.
Notice how they remove the video because it's
truth. Now, I don't know what video she's
referring to, but the article she sent has nothing
to do with proof of people dying from the vaccine.
They aren't lawsuit documents. It's merely an
article which says PCR tests can't tell you if you
are actually ill with something. And we know that.
And that has nothing to do with covid. PCR tests
are designed to tell you is a particular signal
present in a swab. You might physically have some
virus particles in you and you might not actually
be sick. That's not news of any kind. And so
I wrote back at this point and I said, Amy, you
said you had proof the vaccine is killing people.
This is an article about testing. Can you send
the articles you mentioned about vaccines as
well as the lawsuits? And I never heard from Amy
again. Now, there are certainly some anti VAX
conspiracy theorists who would have things to
send me. And if they did, I would evaluate the
sources in the past. They're very disreputable
websites, you know, natural news type sites and
things like this. But this is a great example of
the types of thinking we're dealing with where
me wanting the information or not wanting it
both are part of the conspiracy. Finding the
videos she's referring to would be proof of the
conspiracy. But if she can't find them, that's
proof that someone removed them in order to cover
up the conspiracy. And so I think the takeaway for
me is obviously, you know, this this took an hour
out of my day. It's not plausible to do what with
this is a retail strategy to disabuse people
of these notions now, because Amy ultimately
couldn't find any of the things she said she
was going to send me. Did she change her views
even? Probably not. What I did probably didn't
even change her views. And this really goes to
the difficulty in dealing with this type of
conspiratorial thinking. We've done interviews
with experts on conspiratorial thinking and
conspiracies, and they pointed to the same thing.
Let me know what else maybe we
can learn from this, but certainly
an illuminating moment in illuminating
just how much of an uphill battle
this is. And I'd love to hear from you.
You can find me on Twitter at Dipak